governor siselek wrapped up his latest
covid 19 response update just a little
while ago
announcing a statewide pause in response
to covet 19
numbers rising but he is not imposing
any shutdowns
8 news now reporter vanessa murphy was
listening in and is standing standing by
with the latest on this
vanessa
sasha the governor is trying to take a
more targeted approach with what he's
calling this
three-week pause as you mentioned to
avoid another
shutdown he calls what's happening here
in nevada with the covid19 numbers
a wildfire and he's saying hopefully
newer restrictions
will help get these numbers under
control this all goes into effect
on tuesday so here are the big takeaways
number one
places considered high risk areas have
reduced capacity from
50 percent to 25 percent that includes
gaming restaurants gyms museums and
additional places number two
he says nevadans should wear a mask
indoors and
outdoors when around other people and
even during private gatherings
number three he says there are
restrictions on private gatherings to
10 people or less and only two
households here's what he had to say
there is a light at the end of this
tunnel and we are getting closer
but we do not have a vaccine yet
there is no doubt that this surge is a
global and national problem
but it's our problem as nevadans to fix
what we can fix
within our own state
as far as enforcement governor siselek
seems to be leaving this
up to local jurisdictions he also
referred to
agencies like osha which investigate if
they receive
complaints and issues are reported
here's what he said when i
asked him about enforcement of these new
rules
how do you plan on enforcing
for example limitations on
uh private gatherings and also this
stronger mask mandate you're referring
to
well we are certainly not the mass
police but i have done everything i
could to help spread this virus
it's now incumbent upon all of us as
residents of nevada to do our part
i hope that people understand the
science that we're dealing with
the medical and health care realities
that we are dealing with
and that they will comply with the
directives that are in place
now governor siselek says brothels strip
clubs day clubs and nightclubs must
remain closed
places that are not seeing additional
restrictions though
hair and nail salons massage places
and spas so again sasha it's it's a
targeted
approach we are seeing record coved 19
numbers
here in nevada governor sislak is saying
look let's take these three weeks
see if we can get it under control if it
is not
under control after these three weeks he
is not ruling out another shutdown but
again he is
trying to avoid that because again he
has to balance
the public health and the economy and
that first shutdown
had a devastating effect on our economy
since we rely so heavily
on tourism back to you yes vanessa and
governor siselek spoke about the danger
of hospitals being overwhelmed which of
course is one of the main concerns when
coveted 19 cases spike
so could you speak a little more about
the struggles hospitals are facing with
an
influx of patients
that's right we actually heard about
this friday during a call with the
covid19
director for the state an
issue is health care staffing and
governor sislek mentioned this
during his press conference today you
have to think about health care workers
possibly getting sick their families
their loved ones whether they have to
quarantine
so right now healthcare staffing is an
issue they are asking for
volunteers through the battleborn
medical corps
i'll send it back to you